i heard michael and some other guys say
they played a new pair of shoes
every game uh i played i played in mine
probably at least a week to two weeks
because i told those guys i played in
michael's shoes one night and i'm the
heaviest damn things in the world
he can really fly if he can jump in
those heavy ass shoes
hey what's up everyone this is meech
from the br kicks team and i'm here
today with charles barkley and the aaron
fox talking about a special release
coming up
the air max 2 cb-94
it was really interesting about this too
my shoes are really light
and i tried to do a tribute to michael
when they retired the first time
and i played them heavy ass l jordans
hey and i call that mobile after the
game i said you ought to
you are to go these are the heaviest
damn shoes
i've ever seen in my life and
these things are so light i say
so i was looking for a light but i
wanted to be really sturdy
but when i sit down with taking those
guys i think clearly
i'm a big dude i need some strength
around the souls
but i want my shoes to be heavy is the
signature
sneaker something that's on your radar
definitely definitely but um like like
chuck said
uh it's all about it starts with
on the court or what you do on the court
so i know i have to continue to rise my
game
and carry my team and then you know
those type of things will come
like i'm pretty sure he wasn't thinking
oh a signature shoe before
um i mean he won mvp you know goes to
the finals and it's like cool you know i
did this did that
and now you get the call that's like you
know you're gonna get a signature shoot
so it's a lot of groundwork before you
before you think about that so i know
it'll take a little bit of time but
you know that's what i'm here to work
for darren you're a guy that's
you know lightning fast on the court
right what are you look what are you
looking for in a shoe
versus what chuck is looking looking for
and i would say
when i was like younger i always looked
for the lightest lightest shoe there
possibly was the kobe 4's fives when
they first came out like
super light shoes um and right now
everybody plays in blowtops all the time
uh but then i when i hurt my ankle this
year i kind of went back to playing in
the kobe 9s which were the high top ones
and for me like these cuts that i make
are just like
and then i'm big on footwork too so like
the cuts that i make are so precise
if a shoe can't hold up that thing's
gone
like i've ripped through some shoes
before so um
if i were to ever get a signature shoe i
think i would kind of want it very
similar to the kobe 9
as far as the high top a little bit um
just to make sure because once you man
when you cut like i've seen pictures of
me cutting in low top shoes and i'm just
like how the hell did i not hurt my
ankles like that
chuck i'm curious to know how important
uh was it for you that your sneaker was
able to translate off court is that
something you were thinking about at the
time
well nobody wants to flop right when i
found out my shoe was doing well
you know you know i think i think at the
time
my shoe was sucking to michael and
that was a big deal to me i mean like
i mean like i say nobody and listen i
ain't gonna
bust my boy shaq i love shaq but zach
will say other sneakers nobody was
buying them big ass [ __ ]
no yeah but but listen
it was a great when they told me when i
started getting the royalty checks
and you start counting up like oh man
then i can say you know
other than michael charles your shoes
are number two
i mean hey man i took great pride in
that it's taking that take up a little
uh
deeper step into that um you made waves
a couple years ago with your air max one
right
what was that process like curious man
run run it's crazy so check you know i
went to college for a year
so education so um but for me like
when they asked me what what what uh my
inspiration for she would be
i was like at the time i was like really
big into astronomy
like i just i don't know what it was
about like i just
i love learning about space planets
different things like that like um
so when we went we went through it i
kind of and then i was always big on
math
like math was always my favorite subject
whether algebra pre-power any of that
like it was always my favorite subject
so
um that's what that's kind of what the
colors are from so the colors of the
shoe they're two different
they're two different color shoes and
it's actually based on the planets
and then as you know like i'm making
dragon ball z so people thought that's
what it was
but if you look inside the shoe there's
a long match equation
in the shoe which kind of would give you
a glimpse of really what it's about
so yeah the shoe is really just inspired
by astronomy what is the magical
equation what is
what's the answer to the matter i
couldn't tell you you know i don't know
i don't that that equation was far too
long for me
chuck i want to flip it back to you um
when you first came out and you know you
started hooping you signed with nike
you're rocking
the nike air force the nike air force
and the alpha force yes um
fast forward you know a couple years
you're dominating the league you know mr
20 and 10
uh and then you you're coming off an mvp
right an nba finals appearance and then
now you have your own shoe
describe to me what that feeling is like
when you're in that meeting and they
tell you they're gonna give you your own
shoe
first of all you gotta act professional
but you cannot get to the phone fast
enough to
you calling everybody in the world
yeah yeah it's just it's just exciting
i mean and you know clearly you ain't
already made it
right you already don't made it i mean
i'd already been in a left all star
games and things like that
but like when you get a shoe uh
it's one of the coolest feelings in your
life who was who was the first person
you called what was that conversation
like
as soon as i got back i called my mother
my grandmother
i called my college coach i called a
bunch of my
high school teammates i called a bunch
of my college teammates
because it's really cool i mean you
think about this
i i don't know the exact number but
you can count the guys on probably
fingers and toes
who got their own shoe oh yeah for sure
it ain't like they give away like candy
i mean
you and listen you know you have to be a
hell of a player to get your own shoe
too
chuck the aaron thank you guys for
taking the time to talk to you know
the kicks family uh about the air max 2
cb 94
you guys have any closing thoughts you
want to leave us with well listen
uh when they gave me a list of guys to
do this with
i i said hey man i love d fox
got a chance to spend some time with him
and his mom and he
just like me i was really close with my
mom he's a hell of a player
and i says oh hell yeah chuck want to do
it with d
fox so man thank you for taking the time
young gun
oh no i appreciate it i appreciate you
choosing me i didn't know you actually
chose me when i saw it
it was me and him i'm like one i love
his personality like
always i can light up a room and that's
kind of how i've always been so
i knew it would be a fun and uh
interesting video so it was i'm grateful
for it thank you
thank you guys for taking the time with
us and let's we'll catch you next time
yes sir yep appreciate it